so there's a very recent event where
senior male scientists resigned because
of very controversial remarks he made
about women scientists being crybabies
there are situations that become very
very emotional in in a lab you have
worked so long on something and
something happens and it's destroyed in
my opinion you're allowed to cry I don't
care if your man or a woman that is a
reason to cry people are passionate in
science that's that's the ironic thing
people are so passionate about the work
they spend all of their waking hours
working on this yet they're not allowed
to cry if something goes wrong or you
know something bad happens or even if
something good happens I cried when I
learned I I my paper got into science
magazine I still remember that and and I
think that women not all women but some
women are more open to to that that it's
it's it's a movement that is not really
started yet but needs needs to start
about bringing more positive emotion by
positive emotion I mean real emotion
authentic emotion into the practice of
science because as you know the
stereotype is closed you know
unemotional it's just data it doesn't
matter but the truth is that all
scientists are passionate about their
ideas and what they're doing and that
leads to two passionate emotions that
could include crying or laughing or
celebrating and I know lots of
scientists that that that do show those
emotions but the stereotype is and
perhaps the old guard is that shut down
kind of thing and and the the squall
chain of any show of emotion so I
certainly have had emotional situations
in my lab where I had to tell say
difficult things did people and there
have been tears shed and I have to say
that I've had a journey myself and
learning how to deal with that at first
it's like I don't want you to cry
because if you cry I will cry and
that's terrible so I tried not to have
them cry but my my approach now is look
that's natural if you need to cry you
cry it's just part it doesn't show
anything weak or strong it's just part
of the emotion that's coming out and I
understand that because I'm saying
something that may be difficult for you
to hear and I can see that and you know
that my tagline is scientists are people
too and we have emotions and I think we
need to acknowledge that so I'm I think
it's appropriate that that scientists
step down i think that represents
something that we need to move away from
in science and embrace the fact that
scientists of people and they have
emotions and that were very passionate
people and so crying can happen i don't
care if your man or a woman